kann ich meine arme ins lokal meine
lieben freunde vor einer woche habe ich
bereits auf den ersten teil der hilf mir
folge die verkohlte barbie reagiert in
einer partnerschaft ist es wichtig dass
man sich gegenseitig respektiert und
wertgeschätzt aber solche dinge dürfen
einfach nicht passieren
bist du schon damals baum gefallen oder
was wir haben die folgen meiner letzten
werk schon allerdings nur bis minute 26
geguckt und die folge geht noch weitere
20 minuten also herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu teil 2 von die verkohlte barbie
mit luca bevor man direkten jetzt ein
wenig mit den kunden los gehts euch noch
ganz kurz darüber informieren dass jetzt
gerade die neue podcast folge von sandra
und mir online gegangen jetzt auf
spotify apple music was 30 überall wo in
der beschreibung unter dem video findet
ihr auf jeden fall ein link dazu sandra
und ich stellen uns gegenseitig 10
unangenehme fragen also tickt da können
wir drauf und jetzt nicht bei der
menschen hier waren wir jetzt mal stehen
geblieben also erst mal ganz kurz hier
für alle die es gerade unter euch die
letzte reaktion von mir auf diese folge
nicht gesehen haben dies erst mal oben
verlinkt also guckt euch am besten ist
das video an und dann das hier aber ich
kann es euch auch einfach kurz erklären
dass hier ist der 26-jährige olli und
ihm gehört ein fitnessstudio und das
hier ist seine 18-jährige freundin
namens clara die total in ihn verliebt
ist der oli liegt die klare allerdings
nicht so doll wie die klarer den oli
liebt und deswegen hat der oli nun ein
neues flittchen im fitnessstudio mit dem
er sich soeben vergnügt hat in seinem
büro und das hat klarer gerade
herausgefunden und da schauen wir jetzt
weiter wir haben trainiert mit
runtergelassenen hosen
ich habe hier nur gezeigt wo genau wo
genau das was du als mediales ist am
oberschenkel
[Musik]
dass der busters lbbw die avast mediales
das erklärt natürlich einige er hat mich
angebaggert ich habe aber sofort klar
gemacht ich weiß ich habe eine freundin
finger weg und ja in dem moment als ich
auf dem rhein weist ein bisschen doof
außer war ja klar weiß doch dass du die
einzige bis für mich
[Musik]
also wenn klar jetzt nicht begriffen
dass die einzige für den 26-jährigen
fitnessstudio besucher als lara der
liebt dich wirklich über alles und jetzt
wirklich nur verträge durchgegangen mit
der anderen ja ich liebe den die nase
küssen ich finde ich immer meine
silbermedaille
ja also das geht echt gar nicht wie wir
klarer bitte trendig sofort ist ganz
klar dass der ist nicht ernst mit also
ich finde es wirklich er noch dass wir
zwischendurch immer so stark kräftige
terrakotta pflanzen da haben wir aber
leute ich bin echt gespannt wie das
zwischen olli und klarer weitergeht
also ist klar recht so naiv und wird
weiter mit dem oli zusammensein allein
dass mich das jetzt so krass kümmert
alter die vielleicht doch die zehn ein
bisschen weismachen dass orte hast ja
noch erzählen wollte was nämlich
eigentlich gekommen und ich habe mein
vater endlich soweit
er bezahlt uns endlich die brust op na
ja
so liest sich zwar gerade dabei erwischt
wie du hier mit irgendeiner
fitnessstudio besucherin fremdgegangen
das habe ich liebe dich nicht schlimm
und jetzt heißt mir und die brüste
machen und ich mich ein piercing stechen
lassen meine zähne die lassen wir alle
politischen für dich neid und erdiger
und gleich kommt die nächste damals ich
große langhantel für dich also den ort
kenne ich den köln barbarossaplatz
überhaupt nicht asozial rolle zugefallen
quält clara sich mit sport und strikter
nulldiät achten eine verkehrliche
kombination
ich weiß nicht ob ich das falsch sehe
aber was hat sie denn für schuhe an ja
alles klar
wer waren die klopfen ich meine
natürlich klar dass das mega gesund und
gut und da wird es auch viel schneller
besser abnehmen wenn du läufst du vom
einzug mega energie wenn jedoch zu den
genommen hast vorhin dann solltest du
mich laufen ja herrlich
du siehst aus als würde gleich umkippen
sie ist zu wenig job bei 38 grad im
schatten hat dazu auch noch sandalen an
nur damit sie dabei gut auf mit sandalen
nicht flip flops flughafen sich
weiterlaufen ehrlich seite zusätzlich
mit kacke jetzt wirklich noch weiter
oder was
wir müssen voll auf schlaue tipps kann
sich eine verzichten
ja also olli der kleineren bruder alt
dafür den kann man auch gern mal
ohnmächtig werden
was glaubt ihr wisst was ich jetzt für
eine einwendung rhein habe ich menschen
nicht gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
ich muss mir unbedingt nach zähne
blitzen lassen ja kommen mehr bildung
scheißegal gesundheit scheiß egal
hauptsache gebiet szene und gemacht was
machst du jetzt endlich einen zettel
vorher die hat vorher halt so komisch
angeguckt hat denn irgendjemand gucken
würde gleich wieder hat da treibt die
heiratswilligen hingehen sagt jetzt
nicht sie geht jetzt ins solarium
achtung kacke gehen ich weiß nicht ob
ihr die letzte folge geguckt hat aber
klar hat einen unnormalen sonnenbrand
weil sie täglich mehrere stunden
solarium geht nur um olli zu gefallen
und jetzt geht die da wieder
sie wird von der scharfen erwischt okay
okay ist gekündigt
das gehirn ist doch super arbeit
geleistet die ganze zeit dem areal
torkel sie es halt einfach bei ihrem
einzigen job im solarium gekündigt
worden das heißt erstens kann sie selbst
mehr in das solarium gehen wo sie ja
süchtig nach es zweitens hat sie jetzt
kein geld mehr für einerseits bleaching
und brust op ich glaube mit colitis
kannst du dir ein bisschen abschwingt
verbitte mir die zähne aber sie blieb
sich selbst
ich habe letztens eine an
kommt für dieses ding was man sich in
mund packt und dann drückt man auf den
knopf dann wird es blau und dann halt
dass sie zähne und ich hab mich darüber
ein bisschen schlau gemacht wie vor
jeder korb und ich habe sagen nein weil
das so kranke gesundheitsrisiko mit sich
bringen kann
und jetzt bringt sie ist dass selbst die
zähne was sogar noch
gesundheitsschädlich heiß da kannst du
dir auch gleich die brüste noch selbst
machen klar ja mein reden die mutter
gefällt mir also nicht falsch verstehen
[Musik]
was passiert dann mit dem lied hey ich
habe es gesagt ich habe es gesagt
irgendwas passiert da wenn ich jetzt
echt gespannt sich also die garantie zu
verdanken ist das blut kann nicht sein
oder
das erste mal gehört
wahrscheinlich ist ein fan der pet shop
boys menge voll mit blut darf wieder
nicht werbe freundlich dieses wichtig so
leid das geht nicht so klar
doch das geht nicht nein und scheint
klar jetzt jetzt lädt ja auch gut sonst
wirst du fragt ja auch noch die rtl hat
eine dagegen wird voll oder kaffee
ich will jetzt endlich ein klarer den
ponys abgewandert galerie so schwer sein
ich war zu gucken ja klar jetzt das ist
aber gerne liebe kommt witzig
jetzt gibt lara soli in jim und die
folge geht auch nur noch drei minuten
also ich bin gespannt was da jetzt
passieren wird am ende fast jeder gast
im studio
ich hab das doch nur wegen dir gemacht
mein spiel geguckt und ich habe
vergessen meinen eltern du bist doch
mein freund mich für ein paar tage bei
ihr bleiben
siehst du noch ganz da was dran gesoffen
oder alt hier ist schon klar dass ich
nur mit dir zusammen war weil wir jetzt
damit bett gegangen sind und weil du
meine wäsche gewaschen was kann dann ist
[Musik]
klar
sind sie zweiter beziehung und falschen
stelle wie sie haben sie die meine
sorgen nutzen und welche machen
siehst du das parkett sich die tagaus
junge und nein jetzt mein gott raus er
sein alter art dachte echt only finale
und jetzt dem wird sich der mich warum
macht oder ist so also da sehen wir noch
mal die wunderschöne stadt in der das
ganze gespielt hat allerdings ein klarer
jetzt glaube ich ihre augen geöffnet
bekommen und weiß jetzt woran die bei
oli ist beziehungsweise war also die
beiden sind jetzt augenscheinlich
auseinander und ich hoffe einfach meine
liebe klarer klingt man das ist dass das
endlich für ein beschissener name lena
ich hoffe dass in zukunft mehr so bleib
so wie du bist und dass du dich nicht
für eine person so krass verändert dass
es sogar gesundheitliche schäden mit
sich bringt an der stelle würde ich
allerdings auch meine heutige reaction
beendet
das ist fühlt sich gut an wenn man so
eine hilfe mehr action ende da fühlt man
sich automatisch ein bisschen klüger das
heutige video gefallen hat da würde ich
mich sehr sehr wohl über einen daumen
hoch von euch hier unter dem video hier
freundschaften wir 50.000 daumen hoch
das ist eine mega krasse zahl und es
wird mir zeigen hey luca wir wollen mehr
hilfen reactions laut doch vielleicht in
einer woche eine reaktion auf ein neues
video hochrhein gehen könnte mir auf
jeden fall gerne videos auf die
reagieren soll unten in die kommentare
schreiben und zudem gern meinen kanal
abonnieren
denn dann verpasse keine videos mehr und
wenn ihr schon aber dann könnt ihr auch
gerne auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommt er eine benachrichtigung sobald
meine neuen action online und jetzt
kommt das auto präsentiert von
[Musik]
es ist zwei uhr in deutschland